thank you to all of my supporters on
patreon this video will explore the
musical characteristics of Robert
Schumann's piano works in celebration of
his birthday June 8th I'll first go over
21 points of observation that I've
gathered then we'll share with you a
version of happy birthday that I wrote
as I were to imagine how human would
have composed it
let's first start with the sweet and
simple melody that is innocent and
unassuming in nature
here's another example the melodic
nature of his music is often very song
like note that there's a dotted rhythm
pattern to the melody which adds a
gentle galloping nature to the music in
a lot of Schumann's piano music the left
hand has an undulating motion
also with syncopation there's a constant
flowing nature to these phrases as you
can see here the spacing in the left
hand is spread up
here's another example of something with
closer spacing in the left hand
and now here it is with wider spacing
[Music]
the same applies for the upper notes of
a figure here is something with narrow
spacing and now again with wider spacing
often times you'll find sixth intervals
which further adds to having a sweet
quality
[Music]
triad inversions work great for this
because the outer intervals are 1/6
his harmonies generally have a strong
tonal Center although he uses a lot of
chromaticism and has frequent
modulations in moments of drama and
tension
srimant often uses chromaticism and
flourishes with diminished chords now
let's take a look at these three notes
adding appoggiaturas to them helps
create a yearning quality now here it is
with notes filled in to create triad
inversions one of the key components of
Schumann's music is having a broad
shifts in mood they often include having
a sudden burst of euphoria many of his
pieces come in the form of miniature
movements often grouped together in a
suite and hear meet Florestan Truman's
alter ego that is impulsive dramatic
extroverted and a bit troubled a lot of
the Rajasa tea is contained in a sort of
classical language rather than being
overly excessive the contrasting
character is you say B Asst who is
introverted sensitive and contemplative
[Music]
in line with these character contrasts a
wide range of dynamics occur in his
music and again Schumann is never shy
about quickly switching emotional gears
[Music]
these shifts often follow the arcs of a
narrative story that is being implied
the script of titles often help in this
regard another common theme is to have
march-like excursions that are poised
with an air of optimism
and of course you'll find plenty of
contrapuntal lines that add complexity
to the texture now with all of that in
mind here is happy birthday in the style
of robert schumann
[Music]
you
[Music]
follow the link in the description to
check out other birthday homages I've
released previously thank you for
watching and I'll see you in the next
video